-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden traveled today
to New York City.
So, yeah, those
Times Square Elmos
made some good money.
[ Laughter ]
In his speech yesterday
about the Senate's
bipartisan immigration bill,
President Biden said
that Republicans
are unwilling to pass
the legislation
because they're, quote,
"afraid of Donald Trump."
Uhh, he tried to have
his vice president killed.
I would be, too.
That's like saying
no one's willing to work
at Camp Crystal Lake
'cause they're all
scared of Jason.
It's a valid concern.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden campaign
is reportedly worried
that the Justice Department's
final report
about the mishandled
classified documents
found at his home
in Delaware
might contain
some embarrassing details,
like how he lives
in Delaware.
[ Laughter ]
Election officials in New York
yesterday
decided to keep
former President Trump
on the state's Republican
presidential primary ballot.
After all, it's one of
the few things left here
that still has
his name on it.
[ Laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
attended a SoulCycle class
over the weekend
in Los Angeles,
and attendees
were reportedly patted down
by the Secret Service.
Said attendees,
"Where could I possibly
be hiding anything?"
[ Laughter ]
In a New York Times op-ed,
former Trump adviser
Kellyanne Conway
said that she would suggest
he pick a person of color
to be his running mate.
I don't know, he managed
to win last time
with a running mate
who was completely colorless.
[ Laughter ]
The only reason you can
even see Pence in this picture
is because he's blushing.
[ Laughter ]
Former Fox News host Tucker
Carlson announced yesterday
that he will interview Russian
President Vladimir Putin.
And while they may not
speak the same language,
they also kinda do.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Tucker Carlson plans
to interview Vladimir Putin.
As for why he chose Putin,
it's pretty simple --
Hitler's dead.
[ Laughter and groans ]
And that's how I feel
about that.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump last
night called on conservatives
to end their boycott
of Budweiser brewer
Anheuser-Busch
over its association
with influencer
Dylan Mulvaney
and said it is, quote,
"A great American brand
that perhaps deserves
a second chance."
Because if there's one thing
Trump believes in,
it's unlimited chances.
[ Laughter ]
Filmmaker Martin Scorsese
is set to premiere
his first Super Bowl commercial
ahead of Sunday's game,
which will push back the kickoff
by more than three hours.
[ Laughter ]
ESPN, Fox, and
Warner Bros. Discovery yesterday
announced a partnership
to launch
a sports streaming service
that would bundle
all their offerings
into one package.
This is like when Uber
invented the taxi cab.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Kinda how I thought
that joke might go.
So, in a way I'm right,
but in a way bigger way,
I'm wrong.
[ Laughter ]
Pizza Hut is offering
a so-called goodbye pie,
which they can have delivered
to their soon-to-be ex.
I don't know, I feel like that
could go a lot of different ways
for the delivery guy.
[ Laughter ]
"I didn't get any tips,
but I got punched twice
and I have a new girlfriend."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities
in Michigan recently arrested
a woman who allegedly stole
an Amish horse and buggy,
after she was found
hiding in a motel shower
under a pile of clothes.
Wow, she really did not like
getting dumped by pizza.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody!